هذا هو الرجل الذي يزعم مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي أنه حاول
توظيف قاتل لقتل
مستشار الأمن القومي الأمريكي السابق جون بولتون
شارام بورسافي المزعوم أنه عضو
في الحرس الثوري الإسلامي الإيراني ،
يقول مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي إنه في عام 2021 حاول بوروسافي
الحصول على مخبر لتوظيف شخص مقابل
مائتي  ألف دولار من أجل
القضاء على شخص نما هذا الرقم في النهاية
إلى ثلاثمائة ألف دولار
لكل صوفي ، حتى أنه أرسل لقطات شاشة
لعنوان منزل بولتون وصور لأكوام
من المال إلى المخبر
prisafee زُعم أن القتل
يجب أن يحدث في مرآب مكتب بولتون
مع الإشارة إلى ذلك.  كانت
منطقة مرورية
كثيفة ، كما يزعم مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي أن بورسافي حصل على وظيفة ثانية مقابل مليون
دولار ، وكان الهدف من تلك الوظيفة
وزير الخارجية السابق مايك بومبيو
وفقًا لمصدر مطلع على
التحقيق ومصدر مقرب من
بومبيو بوزارة العدل قال
هذا  حول الدافع وراء
مؤامرة بولتون التي نفذت مؤامرة الاغتيال هذه
في  انتقامًا واضحًا
لمقتل قاسم سليماني بومبيو في يناير / كانون الثاني 2020 ،
كان وزيرًا للخارجية
وقت الاغتيال ، رأينا
أنه كان يخطط لخطط أخرى
للقضاء على الأمريكيين في بعض الحالات ،
اتخذنا الإجراء الصحيح
للدفاع عن أمريكا وحمايتها.
لم يعد بولتون في
الإدارة عندما تم تنفيذ الضربة الجوية
ضد سليماني على رأس
الجنرال الإيراني ، وقالت إدارة ترامب
إنه كان يخطط لهجمات
على الأمريكيين.  يأمل القضاء على قاسم سليماني
أن تكون هذه هي الخطوة الأولى لتغيير النظام
في
طهران وبعد أخبار اليوم شكر بولتون
وزارة العدل ومكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي والمخابرات وقال إن
حكام إيران كذابون إرهابيون
وأعداء للولايات المتحدة المشتبه به لم
يتم القبض عليه ولكن  مطلوب من قبل مكتب التحقيقات الفدرالي
بعد السعي لتنفيذ ذلك
لم يكن هذا تهديدًا خاملًا
وهذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
نكشف فيها عن أفعال وقحة من
قبل إيران للانتقام من
أفراد على أراضي الولايات المتحدة ، فإن المؤامرة ضد
بولتون هي مجرد ادعاء آخر بشأن
تخطيط إيران لهجمات على الأراضي الأمريكية في عام
2011 قالت السلطات الأمريكية.  كانت إيران
تخطط لتفجير مطعم في العاصمة الأمريكية لقتل
السفير السعودي في الولايات المتحدة
ووزير الدولة السعودي الحالي
للشؤون الخارجية أديل الجبير ،
وهذا يحدث في أمريكا
الأسبوع الماضي فقط الصحفي والناشط الإيراني
ماسي علي نجاد مواطن أمريكي
يعيش  في نيويورك ألقى باللوم على النظام الإيراني
بعد إلقاء القبض على رجل يحمل بندقية هجومية
في
حيها بعد عام من قول السلطات الأمريكية إن
النظام كان يخطط لاختطافها
سلمت هذه الرسالة إلى النظام على
CNN اذهب إلى الجحيم أنا لست خائفة من  أنت
الآن مستشار الأمن القومي بالبيت الأبيض
جيك سوليفان حذر
بعد ظهر هذا اليوم من أنه ستكون هناك
عواقب وخيمة للإجراءات المتخذة ضد
أي من الولايات المتحدة  مواطن نسمع أيضًا من
الجانب الإيراني مع
وزارة الخارجية الإيرانية تحذيرًا من أي
إجراءات ضد المواطنين
الإيرانيين بناءً على ما يسمونه
اتهامات لا أساس لها كايلي أتوود سي إن إن
واشنطن